all right we start tonight house Intel
committee chairman Devin Nunez just
revealed something that should concern
every single American watching this
program tonight the FBI's investigation
into whether or not the Trump campaign
colluded with Russia was started without
a single trend zero intelligence I'm not
making this up take a look the
counterintelligence investigation uses
the tools of our intelligence services
that are not supposed to be used on
American citizens so we've long wanted
to know well what intelligence did you
have that actually led to this
investigation so what we found now after
the investigators have reviewed it is
that in fact there was no intelligence
that's right so the FBI began a serious
investigation of an American political
campaign unprompted by any intelligence
at all Wow now there's more to this
listen to what chairman Nunez went on to
tell our own Maria Bartiromo takes take
a listen we do know that longtime
associates of Hillary Clinton including
Sidney Blumenthal and another person and
I think Corey Scheer were actively
giving information to the State
Department there was somehow making its
way to the FBI this is from this is from
two people within the State Department
who have now publicly come out and said
this in I think in major news
publications we now know that there was
no official intelligence that was used
to start this investigation we know that
Sidney Blumenthal and others were
pushing information into the State
Department so we're trying to piece all
of that together now this is a deadly
serious charge coming from the Intel
committee chairman and remember it was
just a few days ago that the freedom
caucus chairman mark meadows he made a
similar claim and even suggested that
the Obama administration played a key
and vital role in kicking off the
investigation into the Trump campaign
you can't make this up
take a listen but we now see that the
State Department and it appears the
White House at the very highest levels
including the President himself were
involved in this whole narrative of
investigating Donald Trump the
the the messages the text messages that
I've had the privilege of reviewing and
some of the other correlating
information would strongly suggest that
there was not only information given to
the White House but indeed that they
were involved in directing some of the
actions of the department justice and
FBI in the in the fall of 2016 that's
troubling when you see one president
allowing their DOJ to get involved in a
political campaign so do you still think
the Obama White House would never tamper
with a politically charged investigation
think again tonight and according to a
completely underreported part of the
recently released Inspector General's
report about firing Andrew McCabe quote
listen to this McCabe said a
high-ranking Obama Justice Department
official expressed concerns about FBI
agents taking overt steps in the Clinton
Foundation investigation during the
presidential campaign and listen to what
they say quote McCain told us that the
conversation was very dramatic and that
he never had a similar confrontation
like that call with a high-level
Department official in his entire FBI
career we got to think about this now
remember this was all happening while
Andrew McCabe's boss James Comey mr.
book tour was giving Hillary Clinton the
White Glove treatment during the
criminal investigation we know she broke
laws committed felonies as it relates to
the private email server now these two
fired career bureaucrats are likely now
headed towards a major collision course
this is gonna be interesting
you have Andrew McCabe in deep legal
trouble over his lack of candor lying
under oath while serving as the deputy
FBI get director number two and the cave
is probably gonna have to cut some deal
and this may involve turning on that
other guy James Comey McCabe should have
plenty to say now for example remember
when Comey agreed to call the
investigation a quote matter at the
request of that Attorney General Loretta
Lynch and we can't forget James Comey
looked the other way while Clinton
obstructed justice by the leading 33,000
subpoenaed emails acid washing with
bleach pit
destroying cell phones and devices with
a hammer by the way try that at home
good luck and maybe most damaging of all
it was the exoneration before
investigation call me and his team
cleared Clinton of all charges months
before they actually did the interview
of her and 17 other key witnesses now
ironically the initial crime clinton may
have committed and should have been
charged with look at this right up on
your screen our own gregg jarrett and
others have identified this 18 USC 793
miss handling a classified information
is now the very same charge that James
Comey is now himself being investigated
over I hope he's hoping he has a James
Comey in his life after he of course
leaked those memos dealing with his
meetings with President Trump those were
not allowed to be leaked classified
information were in some of them now
this weekend the president tweeted quote
James Comey 'he's memos are classified
I did not declassify them they belong to
our government therefore he broke the
law and additionally he totally made up
many of the things he said that I said
and he's already a proven liar and a
leaker where are memos on Clinton Lynch
and others according to the Office of
Inspector General Comey is now being
probed over whether or not he acted
unethically when he leaked those
potentially classified memos to his
friend that guy is a Columbia professor
his name is Daniel Richmond and of
course we now know that Richmond went on
to leak these memos to the press putting
the wheels in motion for the appointment
of Robert Muller a special counsel now
this is gets very interesting
Congressman Jim Jordan he's shining a
light on this unusual relationship
between Daniel Richmond and the FBI I
had not known this before watch this the
Oversight Committee and the Judiciary
Committee interviewed Jim ray Vicki and
during that deposition it was brought
out that Daniel Richmond the guy who
information was leaked through to the
New York Times had this special status
called special government employees
status where he could sort of come and
go in the FBI which may not mean much
but it seems kind of interesting the guy
that Comey leaks through is a good
friend who had this sort of unfettered
access into the FBI pretty amazing and
congressman Jordan also detailed
possible deep state collusion between
the media and some of the highest
ranking officials in the government over
the salacious anti-trump untrue
unverified Clinton bought and paid for
phony Russian dossier let's take a look
at this clapper I think is the one who
probably went out and leaked it right
after that I mean the press was working
on it CNN the dossier yeah so if you
have the cover of we briefed the
president-elect give then they can
report it gives it weight and that's
exactly what happened my guess is I
don't know this for sure but clappers
the one who orchestrated this he's the
one who told Comey you go and you talk
to the present you're the one saying on
you briefed him on the dossier the
salacious unverified dossier and then of
course right then after that CNN talks
about it
principe prints it and then BuzzFeed
printed the whole thing I know this is
the same dossier that was used to
acquire that FISA warrant against the
Trump campaign associates and remember
they lied to the FISA judges and
remember they never disclosed who paid
for this now make no mistake this was
campaign opposition research bought and
paid for by Clinton her campaign
funneled through that law firm Perkins
cuy put together by a foreign agent
based on Russian and Russian government
lies and used as evidence to get a
warrant during a political campaign
against an opposition party
all the while Comey and his cohorts they
never disclosed the true nature of this
document and they lied to the FISA Court
judge that is a crime which brings us to
our next stop story now the Democrats
laughable lawsuit against the Trump
campaign WikiLeaks and Russia now we all
know this court filed conspiracy theory
it is nothing please understand that
this is a desperate publicity stunt but
breaking tonight the DNC's brand new
lawsuit is now revealing what is almost
an unbelievable double standard all
right so we told you about the
anti-trump dossier they presented that
to the FISA Court they get the warrant
we've been talking about tonight and
nearly every night in this program for
the last couple of months so the dossier
that was used to get the warrant that
supposedly links Trump to Russia in the
most salacious embarrassing ways that
was never verified in this lawsuit it is
nowhere to be found it's not even in
there let's lie to the judge but let's
not lie to the next judge okay I really
understand this so
the Democrats along with the Clinton
campaign were the ones that paid a
foreign spy to piece together this
document on Russian lies and rumors and
so-called Russian intelligence now
listen to what chairman Nunez had to say
about this totally embarrassing
political hair Hail Mary
take a look we know who colluded with
Russians they don't want to admit that
they colluded with Russians but they
hired fusion Jeep they hired a law firm
that hired fusion GPS that hired a
British spy that went and colluded with
Russians so I don't understand why they
just didn't open up a lawsuit against
themselves they should name themselves
and sue themselves so that they can get
to the bottom of what do they have on
their servers why didn't they give those
servers to the FBI this is this is
nothing more nothing less than a
continuation of fundraising off of this
scandal I'm just on believable now
clearly as many are now noting this move
from the Democratic Party whiffs of
nothing but desperation and even some of
the Democratic Party including Claire
McCaskill they're admitting this lawsuit
is merely a distraction by the way she's
up for re-election that's probably just
for political expediency now meanwhile
President Trump he announced his
response on Twitter look what he wrote
just heard the campaign was sued by the
obstructionist Democrats this can be
good news and that we will now counter
for the DNC server that they refuse to
give to the FBI the Debbie
wasserman-schultz servers and documents
held by the Pakistani mystery man and
Clinton emails by the way we'll bring
you more information as that plays out
Luke Rosie akka the daily callers done
amazing work all right finally tonight
we're going to end on some good news
you'll never hear from anybody in the
media despite what I described as the
five forces that have been working to
defeat this president want to prevent
them from getting elected then to D
legitimize him and get them thrown out
of office you have the media you have
the never Trump ruse you have weak
establishment Republicans you have
Democrats and of course the deep state
you know the Trump agenda keep seeing
massive major progress both right here
and abroad now this includes big
progress on the economy look at this 14
states 14 have now here
record low unemployment numbers
including Alabama Arkansas Texas Hawaii
even California Wisconsin now meanwhile
the u.s. is also seeing record low
unemployment for African Americans and
Hispanic Americans and on the
international front we'll talk more
about these developments later late last
week North Korea announcing this is huge
little rocket man they will suspend all
ballistic missile testings and they plan
to close a nuclear testing site and
according to a reports tonight Kim
jong-un also has dropped his demand that
all US troops leave the Korean Peninsula
they can stay in South Korea now this
comes ahead of the president's upcoming
meeting with the North Korean dictator
now these major groundbreaking
developments came as a shock to many in
the mainstream media one fake new CNN
reporter literally became speechless and
this is priceless
take a look Kim jong-un saying North
Korea no longer needs any nuclear tests
mid-range and intercontinental ballistic
missile tests and he sank the nuclear
test site in the northern area near the
Chinese border at home gary has
completed its mission therefore it will
likely be closed this is an
extraordinarily significant development
and frankly a huge win for president
Trump I am really almost speechless here
at the pace at which North Korea has
done this u-turn and this all started
with Donald Trump agreeing to sit down
for a summit that came going on good
news for Trump good news for the world
makes CNN speechless that speaks volumes
now of course what we're seeing tonight
is just the latest in what is a long
list of accomplishments you can see
right there on your screen but you're
likely to never see these things
reported in the mainstream media now I
have been talking about and this message
of these five forces working against the
president these narratives are now dying
especially Trump Russia collusion and
the President's agenda is working which
is good for the American people here's
my final word tonight it's time to put
this hatred this obsessive-compulsive
hatred in the media in the deep state in
the Democratic Party si
work for the American people work for
more peaceful prosperous America in the
world maybe we'll actually get along
anyway coming up just wait until you
meet her upcoming guest Candice oh and
she's joining us later tonight hear
about the support she is receiving from
Kanye West it is driving liberals nuts
and you'll hear a viciousness against
this young woman that will shock your
conscience and also later in the show
tonight I have an answer to the media
which is clearly obsessed with me hi
glad you're watching